who is the greatest drummer of all time
i got a hundred dollar bet going only
lars knows the answer
it's [ __ ] hard i've been asked that
question for 40 years it's
john bonham the great drummer possibly
the greatest drummer that ever lived i
mean who's better than john bonham
this is the 40th anniversary of his
death
when the levee breaks that drum rip it's
one of the most sampled drum beats
ever recorded who's a better drummer
than him what does
our resident drummer think richard you
know something about drummond
you were like voted the best drummer in
the world by some metal magazine weren't
you
one of the top five metal drummers ever
are you in agreement that john bonzo
bonham was the greatest drummer that
ever lived
yes but i would put neil pier
right next to him you mean of rush yep
great drama but come on
who's more iconic bonzo uh that's what
good argument i don't get out of here
get off my show how dare you
come in here tom sawyer drum solo is
iconic there's a sexiness that jon bonzo
bonham had to his drumming
that few have been able to replicate i
am no drum expert but i am very good at
googling and
i googled who is the best drummer ever
and number one
with the bullet was john bonham i put in
google and i just wrote
greatest drummers of all time and neil
pearch shows up first
alexi just said it was ginger baker
i'm not kidding it's up for
interpretation go ahead joe in new
jersey
i think he should call lars he was on
last week i think he's got a true
opinion on this one
lars would say without thinking that
john bonzo bonham was the number one
drummer
of all time how much you want to bet
i'll bet you 100 bucks
get lars on the phone immediately gary i
don't think i could get him on
immediately but i probably could get an
answer by tomorrow i'm betting that lars
will say
john bonds obama and then if laura says
it's neil then you'll give him 100. yeah
that's right
yes that's right joe is on the phone
lars who had the balls to call me up and
argue with me
about john bonzo bonham's drums he says
neil peard is better it's a blah blah
blah blah blah
lars is the expert let's find out what
lars thinks
uh it's [ __ ] hard listen i've i've
been asked that question on and off
40 years are our two choices for
greatest drummer
which is uh bonzo bon moneil peer i mean
you got ginger baker you've got
keith moon you're talking about a lot of
different people i would put two
additional names
on that list deep purple's ian pace is
an incredibly
technically gifted drummer and phil rudd
is what gives ac dc that
incredible bounce and swing this was the
point i was making about bonzo bonham
yesterday
there was a soul to this guy's drumming
you mentioned when the levee breaks i
mean that's
classic bottom the drums are big
thunderous ambient he's a little bit
behind on this
and it's got in that groove and he's in
a pocket i like where you're going with
your whole buildup i think
maybe we want to hear your opinion of
neil
the first time i ever uh met neil it was
1984
our manager cliff signed rush and i have
drum questions about gear
and this and that he goes neal loves to
talk to younger drummers
he goes call neil he wants to hear from
you and it was like
huh i was uh 20 years old
well not a part to prison and uh i
called him and we spoke
30 45 minutes on the phone and we're
geeking out on drums and
the whole thing was like a fairy tale
you can't
play drums and not love neil and you
cannot
be appreciative and respectful
uh and but
listen uh oh no i mean territory i mean
i didn't know i didn't know lawrence was
getting drum lessons from neil peard on
the phone i mean
jesus christ watching him talk about
neil i'm like he's in love
[ __ ] there goes my hundred dollars
this is the big uh is there a drum roll
uh can we have a drumroll
between neil and between john
no disrespect but i'll have to go with
john bonham
i knew it joe joe you give that hundred
dollars to my charity